today with liberal critics saying all
the president cares about is getting
this border wall he made it clear this
is not about politics this is really a
bill on border safety border security
and it's a bill on I would say maybe
more than anything else we're talking
about drug trafficking well joining me
now with reaction counselor to the
president Kellyanne conway Kellyanne
what is the White House's message
tonight to those Republican senators who
look poised to reject the president's
emergency declaration including and it
breaks my heart
Mike Lee of Utah ok Murkowski doesn't
surprise me at all but Mike Lee and Rand
Paul you're on my you know what list
tonight I'm sorry
it is a pollen I was in two separate
briefings with the president today and
in both both times he said take the vote
you want to take but I think it's a bad
Modi said this was this is an easy
decision is quite binary you either
aren't for border security the
sovereignty of this nation keeping the
drugs out of our communities Laura the
human traffickers out the illegal flow
of people particularly those
unaccompanied minors and families coming
from the northern triangle or you're not
and he doesn't believe you can divorce
the two just because you want to hide
behind a process argument he is focused
on the substance as he has been for four
straight years now and the substance is
very simple when you look at the drugs
flowing in not just at the ports of
entry but we saw data today about all
the fentanyl this ultra lethal synthetic
opiate that's coming between the ports
of entry a very important article today
called the fentanyl failure of all
places in the Washington Post brilliant
article the fentanyl failure please
folks please read it it defensible
failure refers to how the Obama
administration did absolutely nothing
nothing to mitigate and curb the rising
event that the synthetic opiate that
that now has claimed about 67,000
Americans more than Vietnam Iraq and
Afghanistan is not a crisis put together
but not Hardy little green tiny little
green Laura is lethal
Kellyanne but I gotta go back to two
what's happened on Capitol Hill now
they'll make a constitutional argument I
think your your White House counsel's
office clearly is right that this was an
absolute delegation of congressional
authority to the president in the 1970s
to declare emergencies now they want to
claim they didn't do that well they did
it if they want to change they should
change that law but on the on this
question of what's going to happen next
the president will veto this if the if
it gets rejected which it looks like you
will he'll veto it and then what happens
at the border with the construction of
the wall what happens well the president
will look at the options and obviously I
know we've been talking about the wall
for two years what options well but
that's not that's not his fault
Republican Congress failed him first now
the Democratic Congress says this
president has made clear that he wanted
money for the wall funding remember
Laura when he signed that on the bus
funding package he said I don't like it
but there's 716 billion for the troops
it just went up to 750 billion there's
there's all this money for the troops
we've got some other stuff in here that
we're funding like the opioid crisis
like some other measures and then he
said but don't you have to give me the
wall funding the Republican Congress
said sure we'll get you that funding
this Congress and they didn't do it and
now that the Democrats certainly I'm
gonna do it but you know what this
president says every day he's moving on
with the construction and this new
budget has thirty two point five billion
for border security measures that
includes additional Border Patrol agents
that includes technology enhancements
but it also includes money for the wall
the military construction funds the the
drug diversion which you still don't
know where you get the money though I
get with it we all know what the
president wants but tonight do we not
know where we're getting the money and
you guys about a lot of time isn't it
well it's in the budget we figured it
out many times if they want to look at
these Republicans who know this
president is within his full legal
authority to declare a national
emergency after he gave them month to do
their jobs Laura at the courts and the
Congress have failed to do their jobs on
the immigration for decades this
president used the declaration on a
finger as his court of last resort I'm
just trying to figure out where
we're spending money facing up the
country's borders Killian we the Syria
Iraq and Afghanistan bring this money
home enforce our borders I think most
everything what's the heck we don't I
want to get your thoughts on this though
the Democrats love to say that the
president or his allies Kellyanne
dehumanize folks let's watch trump
dehumanizes name calls degenerates
people dinner grates people did you have
a man that has the humanized children
taking the children from their parents
this is just an extension of the Trump
brand this dehumanization of immigrants
okay Kelly Ann what are the Democrats
reaction then to this Jared Ivanka just
on the facts forget the book for a
second they've outlasted everybody is it
a sign that loyalty is preeminent with
the traumas yeah I don't think so no I
think mediocrity is Aminu to mediocre
even for Donald Trump you really got a
problem and of course they survived
I mean cockroaches are gonna survive
nuclear war Kellyanne cockroaches we
know the word vermin used by Hitler's
coterie to describe do something I found
that to be go ahead oh it's beyond they
you know the word dehumanization
absolutely applies to the way so many
people have treated those of us who work
in the White House but so what I'm gonna
give you a little news flash we don't
really care they've been trying to cut
us down and push us out since we arrived
and those of us who are there for the
right reasons and are surviving all of
this and thriving beautifully it doesn't
matter and I know that's true about
Jared and Ivanka as well the media don't
like to cover anything that they're
trying to do her global Women's Fund or
what he's done on criminal justice
reform or a Mideast peace my trade
certainly the u.s. MCA President had a
big meeting no they don't want to cover
anything but you know what I'm not sure
it matters so much I think the media
matter to themselves and to each other
there's a lot of noise and a lot of
nonsense out there I think people know
that they're doing much better but you
know what I'm glad
played all those clips for another
reason stop the nonsense everybody about
we are for all women we are pro women
here for independent thinkers you have
running for president she tried to
appropriate somebody else's ethnicity
she lied about the Hat they've got a
bunch of it I like to say I don't see
any presidential timber yet just
presidential wood chips yeah Kellyanne
thanks so much it's great to have you on
tonight